- Andy Barclay was born
on November 9th, 1982.
We know this because his 6th birthday
ends up being the same day as
Charles Lee Ray's deathday,
which we see here and here.
There's also one document suggesting
that he was born on January 4, 1983,
however, this isn't an official file,
this is just the toy
company's file on him,
so it may be less likely to be accurate.
Later on you'll see why it
probably isn't accurate,
but we'll get back to that.
As a kid, Andy's favorite
food is chocolate,
and he also likes eggs.
At night, his mom would sing him to sleep.
Andy's father is not around anymore.
The original script of "Child's Play"
mentions that he had
died in a car accident,
however, I won't consider that canon,
as it's not in the movie.
We first meet Andy on his
sixth birthday in 1988.
He woke up early to watch
TV and, disastrously,
tried to make breakfast for his mother.
He sees the commercial for
the Good Guy doll on TV
and is extremely impressed
and wants one for himself.
He's at that age where
he's so impressionable
that he can easily be swayed
into wanting something
or believing something.
Had he been a little bit older,
maybe what happened next could
have entirely been avoided.
He wakes up his mom and asks
if he can open presents.
In addition to some new clothes,
he gets a Good Guys branded tool chest,
but understandably, he wants
a Good Guy to go with it.
That evening, his wish would come true,
when his mom surprised him with one.
- Hi, I'm Chucky, and I'm your
friend to the end. Hidy ho!
- This would be one of those examples
of be careful what you wish for,
as this birthday present
would completely **** up
the rest of Andy's life.
To learn how Andy grew up to
adapt to childhood trauma,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Surfshark VPN.
Welcome to Things You Missed....
I just realized this is
actually Horror History.
I said the wrong thing.
Andy Barclay is actually
kind of an outlier
when it comes to slasher
movie protagonists,
in that he's managed to
stay alive the entire time.
He's even mostly been covered
by the same actor, Alex Vincent.
The only exception is in Child's Play 3,
where they wanted to tell
the story of an older Andy
without waiting for Alex
Vincent to get older,
so a kid by the name of Justin
Whalin filled in on that one.
At this point, there's also
a third actor to play Andy,
which would be Gabriel Bateman
in the Child's Play remake,
but that's an entirely
different character,
so that'll maybe be its own
episode of Horror History.
I said the right thing that time.
To understand this Andy,
let's take it back to the
moment that changed everything.
Andy's babysitter for the rest
of his 6th birthday evening
was his mom's friend, Maggie,
who he just refers to as Aunt Maggie,
just because she's such
a close family friend.
When she tells him it's
time to get ready for bed,
Chucky whispers in his ear
that he wants to stay up
and watch the 9 o'clock news.
Perhaps an older child would have realized
that something was wrong here,
that the doll shouldn't
have the capability
to communicate with him with
the context of the time of day
and what was on TV.
However, as a kid, you're
still learning about the world,
and you tend to believe
what you see at that age
and perceive it as normal.
Andy gets in trouble when
he's brushing his teeth
and Chucky walks into the living room
and turns on the TV anyways.
- I didn't do that.
- Oh no, what did Chucky do,
walk into the living room and
turn it on all by himself?
- Maggie lays him down to
sleep, and when he awoke,
his life would be changed forever.
He's woken up by a man named Mike Norris,
a homicide detective with the
Chicago Police Department,
who informs him that
Maggie had an accident
and starts asking him questions.
His mom returns home
from work, very worried,
and she orders Andy to stay in his room.
He realizes that the tiny
footprints on the counter
near the scene of the accident
match Chucky's footprints,
but the adults obviously
don't believe him,
and this opens him up
to be psychologically
manipulated by Chucky.
His mom thinks that he's
being a troublemaker
and telling stories, and again,
there's no father figure in his life.
There's a natural tendency for a child
to attach themselves to an adult.
It's basically their survival instinct,
since they can't yet
take care of themselves.
Karen Barclay is a struggling single mom,
she's exhausted, she can barely afford
to get care for her son
and she has to spend
a lot of time at work.
Psychology studies show
that lack of a father figure
can lead to low self-esteem
and misbehavior,
and Chucky essentially tries
to manipulate the situation
by inserting himself into the father role,
forcing Andy to attach himself to him.
Chucky tells him his real
name is Charles Lee Ray,
and that he'd been sent down from heaven
by his daddy to play with him.
He does this to try to
gain control over Andy,
the way a father has
control over his child.
Andy doesn't have the life experience
to know how this looks from
someone else's perspective,
and eventually just apologizes
and promises to stop making up stories
to appease his mother.
The next day he brings Chucky to school,
but Chucky tells him to
sneak out before class
and take the El Train to 23rd Street,
already demonstrating his
psychological control over him.
He's guided to a rundown house
where Charles's old accomplice,
Eddie Caputo, is staying.
Andy puts down his Chucky doll
and wanders off to go piss,
but can't find Chucky when he gets back.
He hears gunshots from inside the house,
and probably not knowing
what the sound was,
he wanders up to it, but lucky for him,
he doesn't get too close
before the place explodes.
The explosion draws in a police
presence and they find him,
pick him up, and call his mom.
Once again, his mom is
relieved to see that he's okay,
and she tries to explain to him
that nobody believes him about Chucky,
and if he doesn't start telling the truth,
they're gonna have to
take him away from her.
Which is honestly kind
of crazy, in my opinion.
I mean, kids are kind of dumb.
I mean, we all saw him
try to make breakfast.
He's not insane for being a six-year-old
who thinks his talking
doll is alive, is he?
Don't a lot of kids have
imaginary friends at that age?
I feel like they're overreacting here.
Andy tries to get Chucky to
say something in front of them
to prove that he's sentient,
but he just gives a generic
line, so Andy gets frustrated.
- [WRESTLING ANNOUONCER]
What is this maniac doing?
- He's asked by the County
General, Dr. Ardmore,
to spend a couple of days with him
for a psychological evaluation.
Andy is already not gonna be considered
that reliable because he's a small child,
but the reactions that
Chucky is drawing out of him
even further delegitimize him,
which is exactly the plan.
The next day, he's locked
in a room at the institution
and sees the doll coming
for him from out his window.
And he's giant now, because
they used a human actor
for this shot instead of a puppet.
Of course, the doctor doesn't believe him
and has other things to attend to,
so Andy breaks down crying.
And it's here that we see the first step
of the boy's maturation.
Crying is often a tactic
used by young kids
to get their way, which
is how the doctor sees it,
but in this case, he's got
kind of a legitimate reason,
because he genuinely believes his life
is about to be cut short
at six years and one day.
Fortunately for him, he's
kind of a creative kid
and comes up with a better plan.
Just as Andy Barclay needs a solid plan
to keep himself safe from Chucky,
I think everyone should have a plan
to keep themselves safe
when browsing the web.
That's why this video is being
sponsored by Surfshark VPN.
I know I should have done
this for the Jaws video,
but the timing just didn't work out.
Ever use public Wi-Fi at a restaurant,
coffee shop, hotel, or airport?
Without a VPN, your personal
data, including passwords,
photos, and credit card
info, can be compromised.
But with Surfshark, your
personal stuff is shielded.
That includes your location,
and you can actually use the
VPN to spoof your location
so that websites think
you're in another country.
For example, by changing my
location and using Netflix,
I can watch six more Chucky movies
than I can in my home country.
With a single Surfshark subscription,
you can connect on unlimited devices.
I've literally never seen
anyone offer that before,
so that's great, but what's
even better is the offer
that they're giving CZsWorld viewers.
By using the link in the
description or entering code: "CZ",
they will give you 83% off.
83%.
That's basically almost
free at that point.
You'll also get three
extra months for free,
and there's a 30-day money back guarantee,
so if you don't like it,
you still have plenty of time to cancel
without getting charged for it at all.
Again, just click that
link in the description,
or enter code "CZ" for
that ridiculous price slash
to get started on Surfshark VPN.
Knowing he doesn't have much time
before the possessed
doll, Chucky, gets to him,
Andy sets up a decoy in his bed
and hides under the
table to wait for Chucky
to enter his room.
It's a pretty clever plan,
and it shows how his survival instincts
force him to grow up
faster than a normal kid,
something he would pay
for with PTSD later on.
When Chucky investigates,
Andy locks him inside and
runs to the surgery room.
Chuck is able to escape out the window,
and he attacks Andy from above,
so he arms himself with a scalpel,
but Dr. Ardmore comes in and
wrestles it from his hand.
He's gonna sedate him
with some kind of shot
when Chucky grabs the scalpel
and instantly ends Dr. Ardmore's chances
of becoming a basketball star
by slicing his achilles tendon,
then instantly ends Dr. Ardmore's chance
of becoming anything other
than the late Dr. Ardmore
by giving him a taste of
his own shock band thing,
which I don't know what
that thing is exactly.
Andy remembers his mom's instructions:
to go home if he's ever in trouble.
Even though he's a little ****,
I gotta give him credit
again for being able to find
his way back to the apartment
in downtown Chicago.
When I was six, I actually lived
less than two miles from his building,
but the center he escapes
from is not close to that.
At least not in real life.
He probably had to take the train again,
but this time without Chucky
to guide him through it.
I guess the kid's got some
street smarts after all.
He hears Chucky approach and
emerges with the baseball bat,
but Chucky makes like a
Kyle Hendricks change-up
and evades the bat.
And that's actually a bad analogy,
because Hendricks likes
to pitch to contact,
but as I'm recording this in 2021,
we don't really have swing and miss, guys,
I mean, maybe Justin Steele,
but it's a bit early to tell,
so I'm working with what I got here.
So anyways, Chucky chases him
around the apartment with a knife,
then eventually knocks
him out with the bat.
When Andy awakes, he finds
that he's been saved by his mom
and Detective Norris,
but they aren't out of the woods just yet
because Chucky just won't die.
His mom traps the doll in the fireplace,
and we see how Andy has matured
past his dependency on
Chucky as a father figure
or as a companion.
- Andy, no, please. We're
friends to the end, remember?
- This is the end, friend.
(Chucky screaming)
- However, he wouldn't totally
get over that friendship right away.
Despite being burnt to a crisp,
Chucky still causes more mayhem
until Norris is finally able to end it
by shooting the doll through the heart.
But a lot of damage is done,
because Andy witnessed all
of this horrendous stuff
up close and personal.
The whole ordeal represents an environment
of domestic turmoil,
which the National Library of Medicine
cites can result in
Developmental Trauma Disorder.
A child's brain still spends a lot of time
developing after birth, and
it may react to these events,
causing abnormal behavior.
Some symptoms include hyper-vigilance
and inexplicable fear,
deep-seated shame and isolation
from making connections.
Dr. Arthur Becker-Weidman does a good job
of explaining this in an interview
at NYU's Child Study Center.
- Their stress response
system is always activated,
and the stress response
system is focused on survival.
- We see this in the final shot
of the original Child's Play
as Andy stares at the severed head,
perhaps unable to believe
that Chucky is really dead.
He's not gonna let his guard down today,
or during the years that would follow.
Andy had to testify in court.
His mom backed up his
story, but the police,
for whatever reason, did not,
causing Mrs. Barclay to look crazy
and be sent to the loonie bin.
The judge ordered
psychiatric care for Andy,
landing him in the Midtown
Children's Crisis Center.
He's haunted by bad dreams of Chucky,
but he doesn't wanna talk
about with his psychiatrist,
an example of his emotional
isolation caused by DTD.
Instead of telling about his
bad dreams to the shrink,
he tells what actually happened in 1988.
It is October 1990 when Andy
is designated for foster care,
assuming this calendar is
accurate to real weekdays.
The Center tells the foster parents,
Phil and Joanne Simpson,
that the stories about the doll
were some kind of coping mechanism
for what really happened.
- Well, in order to come to terms
with something he couldn't
possibly understand,
he turned it all into
a kind of fairy tale.
He insisted his doll was responsible.
Said it was possessed by
the soul of Charles Lee Ray.
- On the way home,
they're nearly flattened
by a Good Guys truck.
The dolls and merchandise
are still popular,
and this makes it much
harder for Andy to recover,
because he's constantly being
triggered into high alert.
After meeting his new foster sister, Kyle,
his PTSD is activated once again
when an old Good Guy doll
falls out of the closet.
That night, Joanne reads
him a bedtime story,
hoping to give him a sense of normalcy.
Andy really misses his mom
and doesn't wanna be left alone,
because even now, nearly two years
after his two days with
Chucky, he's paranoid.
He asks Mrs. Simpson to sing him to sleep
like his mother used
to, but as he dozes off,
he's still alarmed by sounds in the night.
The next morning, he and
Kyle are both grounded
when this broken statue is discovered,
so Andy helps Kyle with the laundry
and takes a puff of her cigarette
while holding it for her.
She tries to explain that
cigarettes are bad for him,
and that only grown-ups
are allowed to do things
that are bad for them,
which he counters by saying
that she's not a grown up,
which gets on her nerves.
I find the dynamic interesting
because smoking is often used
as an unhealthy coping
mechanism by adults,
and Andy is getting involved with it
at a way too young of an age.
But he's seen more agony
than a lot of adults have.
This may also have been a gateway for him,
because he's seen to be a
smoker later on in life.
It seems that Andy is also self-conscious
about the burden that his
psychological issues present.
He overhears Mr. and Mrs. Simpson debating
whether they're qualified
to take care of him,
which plays into the shame
and low self-esteem issues
connected to his psychological issues.
He's also still paranoid.
He sees the Good Guy
doll that Mrs. Simpson
was supposed to have
gotten rid of downstairs,
and he's off put by this small hesitation.
- Hi, I'm Tommy!
- Andy decides to check
the batteries to make sure
this wasn't a repeat situation.
That evening, he hangs out
with Kyle in the backyard.
I imagine it was good for
him to have a real friend.
It goes back to the attachment theory
that I brought up earlier.
He's not as comfortable
with his foster parents,
because he senses they feel
that they can't handle him,
but Kyle's in the same
situation that he's in,
and they kind of bond over that.
The next night, Chucky
makes his move against Andy,
by tying him up and
gagging him with a sock
in order to perform the voodoo ritual
and transfer his conscience
out of the doll's body and into his.
We've already established
that the kid's been dealing
with some nightmare issues.
It's not really something
that's explored again going forward,
but this is the third time
now that he's woken up
to some horrific circumstance
caused by Chucky.
I imagine that makes it
pretty hard to fall asleep.
This time, he gets out of it,
because Kyle had snuck out that night
and she was coming back
in through his window,
forcing Chucky to go inanimate
so that nobody finds
out he's really alive.
This once again put
Andy in a bad position.
He doesn't have an explanation
for how he got tied up,
so he's forced to tell the truth,
which makes him look like a nut.
Andy is still too young to understand
that the word of a 7-year-old
will never convince them,
he needs proof.
Mr. Simpson is fed up with
all of Andy's Chucky stories,
and he locks the doll in the basement.
The next day would be Andy's
first at his new school,
where he would be pushed
to his breaking point
and go on the offensive
for the first time.
In the morning, Kyle walks
Andy to the school bus,
and tries to give him some
advice for his first day,
telling him not to act nervous,
because Andy's constantly
looking back for Chucky.
It's not just Chucky that he
has to worry about though,
there's also this INCREDIBLY
hostile kid on the bus.
I know I bring this up every time,
and you're probably sick of seeing it now
if you watch my channel, but I
just can't get over this kid.
What happened to him? Why is he like this?
But it's here that we
see the isolation aspect
of Andy's trauma fully on display.
He sits alone on the bus and
plays alone on the playground;
it looks like he's actually
just pretending to play
so he can keep an eye out for Chucky.
At the end of the day,
Andy finds a Good Guy doll
hidden in a cabinet and gets
chewed out by the teacher
for writing obscenities on his schoolwork,
which he obviously didn't
do, and ends up in detention.
The teacher locks the doll in a closet,
and when Andy gets up to investigate
and see if this was in
fact Chucky, he sees this.
- [CHUCKY] Peek a boo!
- [ZAC] He finds himself
locked in the classroom
and has to use the window to escape,
but after explaining everything
to his foster parents,
they remember the broken statue
and view this as another
example of Andy acting out,
which they had been warned about
by the center they fostered him from.
Mr. Simpson takes him to the basement
and shows him that the
doll is still lying there
where he left it,
but Andy knows what he
saw at school that day.
In the middle of the night,
he wakes up and steals the
carving knife from the kitchen,
and bravely goes down to confront Chucky,
but the Good Guy is no longer in his spot.
Chucky surprises him from above,
but he's able to recover
in time to slice Chucky
in the head, causing the doll to retreat.
However, the noise wakes up Mr. Simpson,
and Chucky silently grabs a fire poker
to trip him on the stairs.
He's left hanging upside down,
and when Chucky releases him,
the impact breaks his neck,
tallying up another victim
for Charles Lee Ray.
Mrs. Simpson was always the more patient
of the two foster parents,
often standing up for Andy
against Phil's concerns
about his psyche,
but the loss of her husband from something
that she perceives to be Andy's fault,
ends up being her last straw.
Before being shipped back to
the Children's Crisis Center,
Andy tries to warn Kyle
that Chucky is still down in the cellar.
- Don't let him get you too.
- The woman at the Crisis
Center, Grace, puts Andy to bed,
but as soon as she leaves
the room, he's back up,
getting changed out of his pajamas
and into some warmer
clothes and running shoes.
Compared to Chucky's
first incarnation in '88,
Andy's already being more proactive
and not just letting himself be the victim
of what happens to him anymore.
By the time Chucky arrives,
Andy is basically already waiting for him.
We can see how he's matured in this way,
he's given up on trying to
convince the adults to help him,
and he's just gonna do whatever he can
to protect himself on his own.
He probably picked this up from Kyle.
- Every time it happens,
it just makes me stronger,
because it reminds me that the only one
I can count on is myself.
- The fire alarm goes off
in the middle of the night,
and Andy spots Chucky at
the bottom of the stairs
in Kyle's arms.
Grace thinks that Kyle, one
of her former troublemakers,
was the one to pull the alarm,
and pulls them both into her office,
where she's stabbed in
the heart by Chucky.
- [CHUCKY] Snap out of it,
you act like you've never
seen a dead body before!
- I mean, he... he has a point.
I mean, Andy should be
used to this by now.
With Andy at knifepoint, they
sneak away from the center
and get into the back
of a newspaper truck,
where Chucky tries to perform
the soul transfer ritual again,
but is again interrupted by Kyle,
who cuts off the truck driver,
forcing Andy and Chucky to flee on foot.
Kyle chases them back
to the Play Pal factory
where the Good Guy dolls are manufactured,
where Chucky frantically finds
a spot to perform his ritual,
but this time discovers
that he's too late.
From his incarnation,
Chucky only has a limited amount of time
to transfer his soul out of
his body before turning human,
and being stuck in the
Good Guy doll until death.
With possession out of the picture,
his consolation plan is revenge.
You know, if you can't join 'em, kill 'em.
Luckily for Andy, Kyle knocks
over a wall of Good Guy boxes
and takes his hand to help him flee.
A long chase through the
factory's assembly line
culminates when Andy opens
this scalding hot plastic overflow valve
and rushes to save Kyle
from the heat press.
It's interesting to see how he's always
the one to attack Chucky with heat,
and this wouldn't be the last time either.
Eventually, it's Kyle who
grabs a loose air hose
and forces it into Chucky's mouth.
The hot plastic dries around the hose,
causing Chucky's head to blow
up like a balloon and explode.
Like Eddie Caputo's house.
*EXPLOSION AND SPLATTER*
The sun rises as they
walk out of the factory.
- [Andy] Where are we going?
- [Kyle] Home.
- [Andy] Where's home?
- [Kyle] Andy, I have no idea.
- And neither do I,
because we don't see Andy
for another nine years.
According to this file,
Andy is now 16 years old.
If Andy turned six in November 1988,
he would turn 16 in November of 1998.
It looks like there's snow on
the ground, but it's melting,
so I'm gonna go with spring 1999
as the next time we see him.
Andy is put into Kent Military School
for delinquent activities
prompting probation
and juvenile authorities jurisdiction.
We've never really seen
Andy to be a bad kid,
but since most rational
people were of the belief
that Chucky was never alive,
it's easy to blame Andy
for a lot of those things that happened.
However, it's likely that he did
get into some actual
trouble in his pre-teen
and early teen years,
and it's not hard to imagine
that with no parental guidance,
he could have found himself
on the wrong side of the law a few times.
Since Chucky never comes
back between 1991 and 1999,
it looks like Andy did kind of
turn into a delinquent on his own.
So we have to assume that he
was not a well-disciplined kid
and he finds himself in
military school because of it.
When the Colonel reads his file,
he tells him that he'll have to behave.
No more fantasies of killer dolls.
While getting his haircut,
Andy discovers that the Good
Guy doll is back on the market
after being pulled in the
aftermath of bad publicity
and lawsuits from what
transpired at the factory.
That evening, he discovers
his new roommate,
Harold Whitehurst has
been locked in the closet
by cadet Lieutenant Shelton.
It's hard to say for sure
what was going through Andy's head here,
but it looks as if he's still
getting flashbacks of Chucky,
because the way he approaches
the closet is very similar
to when Chucky was locked in
the closet at Andy's school.
During drill formations,
Shelton picks on Andy because he's new,
but one other cadet stands up for him,
which leads to Andy finding a new flame.
Andy takes a liking to a female cadet
named Kristen De Silva.
There are obviously a lot of theories
about dating compatibility,
but it looks like what
they're going for here
is the opposites attract theory.
De Silva is fearless, standing
up to her superior officer,
outperforming her class
at the shooting range
and sneaking around the halls at night.
Andy is traumatized by a children's toy,
can't hit a target and
is basically a runner,
he doesn't seem to stay
in one place too long.
The idea behind this theory
is that we as humans look for a partner
who fills in the traits that we lack,
so De Silva is a natural fit for him.
During marching drills one day,
Andy is distracted when
he sees Colonel Cochrane,
no, not Conal Cochrane, Colonel Cochrane,
carrying around a Good Guy doll outside.
He doesn't have any proof
that it's Chucky yet,
but it is a strange sight to
see at a military academy,
and it causes him to drop
his rifle on the ground,
which gets him in big
trouble with Shelton.
The trainees are drawn away not long after
when they hear the
screams of a garbage man
and run to go help him,
only to find his lifeless
arm sticking out.
That night, Whitehurst informs Barclay
that he's gotta unpack, or
Shelton will be on him again.
We saw the same thing
back at the foster home,
where Kyle had yet to unpack her things
after three weeks of living there.
This tells me that Andy has
also probably bounced around
to a lot of different homes over the years
and doesn't like getting
comfortable anywhere
because he's moved around so much.
Whitehurst also asks him
if he ever got a package,
and he's confused at who
would be sending him one,
and he puts up a picture
of him and his mom
from when he was six.
These two things tell me
that she's probably
still institutionalized;
her life really got messed up
by this whole ordeal more than anyone.
Andy feels a sharp pain in his ankle
and discovers Chucky hiding
under his bed with a knife.
He finds out that this time,
Chucky's just out for revenge.
Previously, Andy's life was protected
because Chucky needed him alive
to transfer his soul into him,
but this time, Chucky
revealed his true nature
to a younger cadet named Ronald Tyler
before getting to Andy.
As a result, Chucky can
only transfer himself
into Tyler now.
However, now being bigger and older,
Andy's able to get the upper hand
and start pounding Chucky into the ground,
but that's when Shelton
hears the disturbance,
comes in and confiscates
the doll, and tells Andy.
- You tell Whitehurst he's off the hook.
I got myself another slave.
- Once again, Andy's not gonna wait
for Chucky to get to him,
so he sneaks out with a knife
while Shelton is asleep,
but Chucky's appearance
causes him to flinch
and wake Shelton up anyway.
We do see how Andy has matured
and gotten a bit smarter
about what he lets out of his mouth,
because when Shelton asks
him what he's going on,
he keeps it vague.
- [ANDY] You wouldn't believe me.
- [ZAC] However, this gives
time for Chucky to scurry away,
causing it to look like the
Good Guy doll had been stolen,
and Shelton forces the
entire dorm to march outside,
hoping to make an example of the thief.
Andy is concerned that Chucky
is going to get to Tyler
and possess his body,
so he tries to bail out of the punishment,
but Shelton catches him
and punches him in the gut.
- [WRESTLING ANNOUNCER]
No way! This is awesome!
- [ZAC] He's forced back
into the marching circle,
where his roommate Whitehurst asks him
what he's trying to prove by
constantly pissing off Shelton.
And after some prodding,
Andy tells him the truth
about the doll being alive
and coming after Tyler.
Like everybody else in Andy's life,
Whitehurst doesn't believe him.
That night, the Kent Academy students
learn of the passing of Colonel Cochrane,
and Andy can already assume
that Chucky was involved in some way.
The next morning, Andy is relieved
to see that Tyler is okay,
and he gets up during breakfast
to warn him about Chucky,
but someone trips him on his way
and the whole dining hall laughs at him,
just highlighting how even
here, Barclay is an outcast.
When he tries to convince
Tyler that Chucky is bad,
he doesn't believe him, so
Andy gives him a pocket knife
to hopefully protect himself with.
His suspicions are heightened again
when he notices Whitehurst
looking like he's seen a ghost,
or in his case: a
children's doll possessed
by a serial killer.
This day would mark the beginning
of Kent Military Academy's
annual war games,
where the student body would
be split into two teams
for a giant game of capture the flag
involving paintball guns
and camping in the woods
to protect your team's flag.
That evening, after Andy's
team has set up camp,
they tell scary stories by the campfire,
and Andy takes off on his own
to try to stop Chucky
before he can get to Tyler,
which is pretty selfless
because Andy's probably gonna be safest
staying right where we he his,
surrounded by an army of
young soldiers in training.
De Silva notices him
break off from the group
and goes after him, and
she shows him an overlook
where the two can see a
carnival off in the distance.
Andy's response as they
share this moment together
really shows how strange
his life has become.
- [ANDY] Almost forgot
there are places like that.
People just go to have fun.
Listen. Somebody's out there.
- It's a perfect example
of why Barclay and De Silva work together.
They're literally hiding
in the middle of nowhere,
and he's concerned about Chucky,
and she doesn't have a fear in the world.
She kisses him, not the other way around.
Alright! That's our boy!
Our little cereal-spilling
brat is finally growing up.
That same evening, he steals a map
from cadet Lieutenant Shelton's tent
and uses it to figure out
where the red team might be hiding out
so he can try to save Tyler.
Whitehurst notices him leaving,
so Andy asks him to go with,
but he won't budge, so as
always, Barclay's on his own.
When he gets to red camp,
another kid tells him
that Tyler went AWOL,
or absent without leave,
with some guy named Charles.
Eventually, he does find Tyler,
and the rest of Andy's
unit catches up with him
as they receive a strange
message over the radios,
in which Chucky tells Barclay
that he must bring the
kid up to the old Jeep,
or there will be hell to pay.
Andy realizes his catch-22
when he hears De Silva's voice
in the background of
Chucky's transmission.
As a group, they all go to the Jeep,
and Shelton instructs Tyler and Barclay
to go ahead and draw them out
while the rest of the troops
circle around the area.
They go ahead towards Chucky and Kristen,
and the rest of the blue
team steps out of the trees
and opens fire, but hits nothing.
Seriously, not a single one
of them hits their target?
I mean, what are they teaching
at this school anyway?
I guess it doesn't make a huge
difference in the end though,
because they're only
shooting paintball guns,
and Chucky has been known to endure
a few real bullets in the past.
The red team, however, is
not using paintball guns.
Chucky switched out their
ammo before the games began,
so they're using real live ammunition.
But since this is the first confrontation
between the two teams,
they don't know it yet.
So when they show up on the scene
and open fire on their opponents,
Lieutenant Shelton is shot and killed.
Was Andy's first thought
that he's not really gonna
miss Lieutenant Shelton?
No comment.
Shelton's second in command,
and presumed best friend,
Major Ellis goes into a
rage and tackles Andy,
assuming he was somehow responsible
given his prior clashes with Shelton
and general connection to any mischief
going on since his arrival.
All of this distraction allows Chucky
to deliver yet another blow
to Andy Barclay's already
reeling team of fighters.
*crickets chirping*
When Andy sees Tyler running after Chucky,
he follows them, and Ms. De
Silva follows him for backup.
They end up at the carnival,
and go to the security tent to see
if maybe someone had spotted Tyler,
but upon their arrival, they
discover the security guard
has already been taken out.
Being the better shot,
De Silva takes the gun
out of the guard's holster.
Andy spots Chucky threatening Tyler
as the two head into the employee entrance
of the Devil's Lair dark ride,
which, I mentioned this in
my Child's Play 3 episode
of Things You Missed, but
this carnival ride is so cool.
It's better than a lot of
actual permanent dark rides.
I mean, it's certainly got Superstar Limo
and Garfield's Nightmare beat,
and probably a lot of others.
De Silva opens fire against Chucky,
and he shoots back,
wounding her in the leg.
Andy ties up her injury, and
she hands the gun off to him
to continue on after Chucky.
This is a significant
moment for his character.
When Andy arrived,
he was the helpless one
being protected by De Silva.
Now, he has to use what she
taught him at the shooting range
to protect her and Tyler.
When Chucky begins the ritual,
Andy remembers everything
that she taught him,
and he's able to land a couple shots,
first shooting off the doll's right arm,
then landing one in the chest.
When he goes to save
Tyler, Chucky jumps on him,
and Tyler unintentionally
pays back the favor
that Andy had done him by
trying to tell him the truth
about Chucky earlier,
by handing back the knife that Andy
had originally given him.
Using that, Barclay is able
to cut off Chucky's other hand
and throw him into the
giant spinning fan blade,
where he dies for the
third time, but notably,
this is the first time he's
vanquished by Andy himself,
and this third incarnation has sparked
the most growth from Andy as a character.
He gets Tyler back to safety
and sees his girl, De Silva, off
as she's carted out in an ambulance.
Right after this, he's
arrested, though it's unclear
if this was for the trespassing,
or shooting a weapon in
public, or if he's being blamed
for what happened to
Shelton and Whitehurst.
At this point, it looks
like he's right back
in the same scenario he's
been in two times before
and he'll probably be kicked out
and find himself on the road
to a new home once again.
However, this time is
a little bit different,
and Andy has himself to thank for it.
Because instead of just crying Chucky
like he had in the past and
expecting people to believe him,
he focuses on trying to
take Chucky down himself,
and this results in many other students
discovering Chucky's
true nature on their own.
I'm guessing because
so many people saw him
with their own eyes, they were
able to back up his story,
get him out of jail, and even prevent him
from being expelled from
the Military Academy.
Barkley would graduate from Kent Academy,
which is not just an academic
and physical accomplishment,
but it also represents a
personal achievement for him,
by being able to find
somewhere to call home
for the rest of high school.
I'm guessing this is also
around the time when Andy's mom,
Karen Barclay is released
from the mental institution
that she'd been locked
in for over a decade.
It's not known what became
of his relationship with Kristen De Silva,
because we don't see Andy
again for another 14 1/2 years.
During that time, he's grown
up and moved into an apartment.
He seems to be a fairly well-adjusted guy,
but that's not to say he isn't
still hiding some demons.
Now this is where the timeline
gets a little bit iffy,
but I'm gonna use the dates
that we're given in the movies
and try to make it make sense.
So there are a couple of
events that happen off-camera,
the first is when Andy learns
about Nica Pierce in the news.
She's a disabled woman from Rhode Island
who claims that Chucky came
and took out her entire family,
save for her and her niece.
Of course, she gets the old
Karen Barclay treatment,
and is sentenced to a mental hospital.
Then, at some point, Andy is attacked
by another Chucky incarnation,
possibly the same one that attacked Nica.
Andy defeats him and
decapitates the doll's head.
He nails it to a board and
locks him inside of a safe.
I'm guessing his intention
was to keep him alive in there
so he could no longer be reincarnated.
I know this is confusing
because these events are out of order
from how we see them in the
movies, but bear with me here.
So the next time Andy appears
is on November 1st, 2013,
as seen in this time stamped recording
where Andy takes the
decapitated Chucky head
to Nica's doctor to try to
prove that she isn't crazy.
This is eight days before
Andy's 31st birthday.
His attempt to free Nica doesn't work,
because the doctor assumes
that it's some kind of
trick or animatronic.
Then we see Andy again on November 8th,
one day before his 31st birthday;
we know this because he mentions
it to his mom on the phone.
- Yeah, I'm definitely coming
for my birthday tomorrow.
No, don't get me anything.
- Yeah, I think Andy loves his mom,
but he's totally cool with her
never getting him another
birthday present again.
As you can probably see from that clip,
Andy has just received another package,
and Chucky is busy
sawing his way out of it.
My thought is that this
Chucky is not the same one
that Andy has locked in the safe,
the dates just don't work out.
- Wait a minute, there's two of them?
- It totally could be a
mistake made by the filmmakers,
but both events are given a date
in the same movie: The Cult of Chucky.
It also shows the date of
Nica's trial: April 7th.
In Curse of Chucky,
there are a couple of things
that happen after the trial,
and then there's the six-month gap
before Andy receives the package,
which basically puts us in early November.
Which is why I threw out that one document
at the very beginning of this
video, if you remember that.
So Andy received Chucky in the
mail again on November 8th,
and this time he's prepared
and blows his head off.
- Play with this.
- [ZAC] At some point,
he checks on the safe,
so he now knows that
Chucky has figured out
how to inhabit more
than one body at a time.
This answers a possible question.
Later on, Chucky doesn't
expect Andy to know
that he can take on multiple
bodies, but Andy does know.
(Chucky laughing)
- [CHUCKY] You thought I was the only one?
Wait! What are you doing?
What's going on?
- Chucky didn't expect
one of the other Chuckys
to be kept alive in Andy's safe.
So when he sends himself in the mail,
he accidentally reveals the fact
that Chucky can duplicate himself.
If you're confused, just
think of it like this.
Chucky gained the ability to inhabit
more than one doll at once.
So he sent one to attack
Andy, which Andy kept,
and then he sent another to
attack Andy before his birthday,
which he most likely killed.
So I'm gonna give you
about 10 to 16 seconds to process that,
and then we can jump back in and analyze
the rest of Andy's story.
At some point over the next few years,
Andy moved to this log cabin.
He uses it to house a very
extensive collection of firearms,
and it seems that he's
become quite the hunter.
I guess old Shelton and
Ellis at the military academy
had an impact on him after all.
Unfortunately for him,
while he's on a date with this redhead,
you'd think he'd steer clear of redheads,
she's put off by his
familiarity with guns.
He tries to explain that
he's not like a gun fanatic,
I mean, I don't know about that,
but rather that he just wants
to be able to protect himself.
When she asks what he needs
to protect himself from,
he realizes that she's Googled
him, she knows who he is.
He explains that he just
didn't wanna scare her off
with his tragic backstory,
but she ends up getting scared
off anyway, and dumps him.
I mean, if she doesn't
wanna get involved with him,
then that's her choice,
but did she really have to wait
until they were already on this
fancy date to tell him that?
Seems like something that
could have been accomplished
with a phone call.
B**ch.
Andy sees his past history with Chucky
as the scapegoat for his
romantic frustrations,
so that night he opens up the safe
and vents those frustrations
into Chucky by torturing him.
Andy keeps a vigilant eye on
the news to try to find out
where Chucky's gonna pop up next,
and in January of 2017, he has his answer
in the form of this Perez Hilton article.
If you don't remember Perez Hilton,
he's like an early internet gossip guy.
He was a blogger before
he got on YouTube in 2007,
and I guess his blog is actually
still going to this day.
I wouldn't have thought it
to be around in 2017, though,
so the fact that Andy's
getting his Chucky news
from basically the forgotten
tabloid of the internet,
means that Chucky is very much
still an urban legend in the
eyes of major media corps.
The article suggests that
Chucky is at it again,
and two patients at the
asylum are now dead.
Barkley doesn't want anyone to suffer
the same fate that he had,
so he decides to try
to intervene once more.
He gets another Good Guy doll,
and this one not tainted by voodoo
or Charles Lee Ray in any way,
and plants a gun inside of it.
He also gives this one a haircut
so he can easily tell that it's his
and mails it to Nica at the asylum.
By doing this, he's basically
giving himself a plan B,
since he won't be
allowed to bring a weapon
into the mental hospital.
This is his way of sneaking one in.
If there's anything we can say about Andy,
it's that he's had no
shortage of creative plans
to make the most of his situation.
While Andy's driving there,
he receives a call from Chucky's
wife, Tiffany Valentine.
Yeah, Chucky does have a wife,
and somehow this is the first time
that it's come up in this video.
She leaves him with a one-word message
that he's supposed to know the meaning of,
and the message is: disembowel.
This may be a setup for something
that hasn't happened yet,
and if that is the case,
it's kind of ironic,
because Andy is about to
disembowel a Chucky doll
to get his gun back.
When Andy arrives at the asylum,
he asks the security guard to
speak with Nica or her doctor,
but the guy informs him that
visiting hours are over.
Because of the urgency of the situation,
he commits himself to the institution
by attacking the guard,
and he finds himself locked
in solitary confinement.
It seems like this measure
might be a little bit extreme on his part,
but remember, he's no
stranger to this kind of care,
that is, being locked up alone
in a psychiatric facility.
He even sits in the same pose
that he did 28 years ago.
After waiting for some time,
his plan starts to come to fruition
when the short-haired Chucky doll,
now brought to life with
the soul of Charles Lee Ray,
breaks into Andy's room and
throws a scalpel into his leg.
However, this is unlike
any Chucky encounter
that he's had before,
because Andy knows
exactly what he's doing.
He pins Chucky to wall and disembowels him
to retrieve the gun.
- This is the end, fucker!
- He uses it to shoot him several times
before stomping his head into
the ground until it's mush.
Unfortunately for Andy,
this is where things stop
going according to plan,
because he soon discovers that Nica Pierce
has already been possessed
by Chucky's soul.
His entire journey was
essentially for nothing,
because this time, he was
the one who was too late.
She locks him in the room and heads off
to cause more mayhem.
The boy who suffered so
much psychological turmoil,
after basically overcoming a bad case
of Developmental Trauma Disorder,
finds himself locked away
in a nuthouse anyway.
And Andy is trapped away
in that room forever.
At least as far as we know,
because that covers the entire history
so far of Andy Barclay.
I'm guessing we will see this
character again before long,
so when that time comes,
there may be an update video,
or maybe I'll wait a little bit
until we get to see more of his story.
Whatever the case may be,
there will be more Chucky content
here on this channel very soon.
So if you can't get enough of the Chuck,
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell for all notifications,
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
(upbeat music)